hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video your
today's Sunday we're getting ready for a
new week ahead and you know what I want
to talk about is you know sort of the
different ways to use order flow you
know that's why I like making these
videos because you know order flow is so
robust there's different ways to look at
it and you know there's no one right way
is there a wrong way well
I think the wrong way is not to use
order flow altogether but let's take a
look at imbalances so you know before I
begin you know if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe to the channel so when
I post a new video you'll be notified of
it and you know be sure to hit the like
button so I know that you guys
appreciate the content that we are
working on so imbalances right
imbalances are important Concept in
order flow
right the imbalance occurs in the
two-way auction between the bid and the
offer if there is more than a certain
percentage you know a certain ratio of
aggressive buying taking place or
aggressive selling so a buying and
balance would be
um you know usually what most Traders
use is uh four to one ratio meaning
there's
more aggressive buying than aggressive
selling in the two-way auction by a
ratio of four to one which is 400
percent and you know you'll see bars
have selling and balances right the net
red numbers in the footprint and the
blue numbers in the footprint the red
number is assignment balance the blue
number is a buying a balance and with
order flow right we have what we call a
stacked imbalances when you have three
or more imbalances stacked neatly on top
of each other right it's a very visual
uh reference you can see here's a
stacked buying imbalance right and you
know software like my order flows Trader
software you have the option if you want
to draw it out because you'd be looking
at it as a support if it's a stacked
buying imbalance or a resistance area if
it is a stacked selling imbalance all
right so
that's just the basic you know most
order flow Traders are already familiar
with that and you know strangely enough
not many order flow Traders really give
much thought to figuring out the
imbalance level right they just sort of
go with a four to one ratio which is you
know sort of an industry accepted
standard but you're not tied to that
there are traders that use three to one
three and a half to one you know five to
one and what I want to talk about is you
know sort of a pet
favorite of mine which is a ten to one
ratio meaning you're going to have ten
to one more aggressive buying or
aggressive selling in the two-way
auction so how you would set it up is
you go look on your footprint chart you
know depending on your footprint that
you're using you got to find the
imbalance trigger in percent okay some
software may call it something else and
change it to ten to one in my software
since it's a percent it would be 1000
right which is ten percent
or not ten percent
um it's a thousand percent which is a
ten to one ratio now
one of the other things to keep in mind
is you know the higher that you go in
your imbalance
percentage or you know imbalance ratio
generally the fewer imbalances you're
going to see and especially if you're
looking at stacked imbalances
you're going to see even fewer of them
so here I have changed it to an
imbalanced trigger in percent of uh 10
to 1 which is one thousand percent and
you can see that stack buying and
balance that we had earlier is no longer
there the stacksana balance is no longer
there but you are seeing buying
imbalances right and selling imbalances
okay now
what I like to do with imbalances is
draw out
areas from where they're appearing
here's a nice here's a stacked
um
buying and balance right here now
generally if you're going to get you
know some sort of sweep through the
market where there's no counter trade
you know and really what is indicative
of a sweep taking place is a bunch of
zeros being left in its wake right you
can see here it's uh zero against
seventy zero against 45 someone just
bought it up basically from 98th and a
quarter all the way up basically to 99
even 99 and a quarter there was very
little counter trade it happened like
super fast it happened within an instant
someone just had a big order you know
they buy you know whatever 200 contracts
okay fine you know 200 shouldn't really
move the market in the e-minis
unless there's no liquidity and you can
see they just bought it up basically a
point really fast okay and you know did
it hold well you know it forms a level
basically you know an area of potential
support and you can see it came down in
there traded there over the next three
minutes now again this is a looking for
stacked buying imbalances at a
percentage of
um you know one thousand percent or you
know a ratio of ten to one and you don't
see very many because to be honest
you're not going to get a lot of
imbalances at a level of ten to one now
sort of getting back to how you can draw
it on your charts you know how to
because you know you have imbalances you
want to be able to use them somehow okay
and you know a ten to one ratio is quite
strong so
what I'd like to do right is I'll go
into my stacked imbalance setting right
I'll make sure it's enabled and I'll
draw it out until tested but what I'll
do is I'll change the
number of imbalances right from three
meaning there's sp3 to just one meaning
there just has to be one and it's going
to draw it out if the next bar doesn't
come back into retrace it all right so
you know make sure it's enabled I'll
draw
um until tested and the minimum amount
of imbalances for a stacked imbalance
has just got to be one so basically if
you just have one imbalance out there
that hasn't been retraced back into in
the next bar it will give me a you know
a potential area that I'd be looking for
the market to come back to
okay so look at this
okay so here we have you know just sort
of going back this is Friday we'll just
go back to the cash open at what time
was that 8 30 and again you know right
after the cash open You See This Bar you
got two zones being drawn out where did
the market come right back you know it
traded above and it came right back
literally to that tick of the lower one
all right imagine if you just if you
knew this level beforehand
right 69 and a quarter
you just put a bit in there one tick
stop
okay
69 and a quarter trades all the way back
up to you know what 75 and three
quarters and again I'm not you know
advocating to say oh you just trade
these all with a one tick stop what
you're going to do is you're going to
build a trading plan around this I make
these videos not to tell you what to do
but to get you to start thinking hey how
can I use order flow
in my own trading right how can I build
a trading plan around it okay here's a
stacked
buying a balance it's two levels right
so it's a minimum of one so it's showing
two right what does Market do it goes up
comes right back it's one tick through
it then goes back up again okay here's
one here here's one here we literally go
up come right back down to these levels
here's you know here's another level
right here you can see it just got
Within one tick of it all right right
here 90 39 80 and three quarters got
within one tick obviously these levels
got through it
here's another stacked one right one two
right and what Market do came right back
down to it and you can start to see you
know hey you know how I maybe I could
use these right if you know everyone
talks I see these
videos and
things you know everybody loves you know
a 99 you know a 100 winning ratio uh you
know 95 winning ratio that's all garbage
you know really what you want to have is
not necessarily such a high winning
ratio is you want to have a low risk
ratio basically you know you want to be
taking trades where you know you could
risk you know a tick or two maybe even
three you know have these areas right
imagine you you know this area could
come back to it right at 96 you know it
just trades back up to 96 and three
quarters and then sells off you know
here it cuts gets within one tick and
then it rallies now
honestly you know just having one
imbalance by itself you know in its own
isn't often very effective right that's
why Traders like stacked imbalances it's
a little bit more effective so what you
want to do is instead of one because one
is one is is not that effective honestly
um especially at a ratio of ten to one
so what I you can do
yeah where's it stacked about you change
it to two so it's got to be a minimum of
two either buying a balances stack
neatly on top of each other
or to sell an imbalances stacked neatly
on top of each other
okay and again you know depending on the
market that you're looking at
um you know maybe bonds you can use get
away with one you know or ten years you
get away with one but you know on a
market like e-minis you're probably not
it's not probably not going to be very
effective so again let's just go back to
the cash open now I'm looking at
an imbalanced level of ten to one
and two stacked neatly on top of each
other right here you're just buying a
stacked buying imbalance again the ratio
is ten to one instead of the normal four
to one and I'm only looking for a
minimum of two
comes right back down to it gets one
tick through rallies back up
here's a staxona balance but the next
bar traded into it we're looking for the
ones where it's like this where the
market goes away from it it then comes
back down and tests it so imagine right
you know this you have a binding stacked
buying imbalance ten to one here 39 you
know 75 and a quarter 75 even you just
put a bit in here with a stop you know
maybe a point away you get filled there
there's another one right you get filled
there a nice move here's a stack selling
a balance it comes right up to that
level and comes off
okay let's see if there's any more in
here
uh he was a stacked buying a balance
okay this one fine would have stopped
you out okay fair enough but you've had
some nice trades and here's just one
it's just unfortunate it just came back
one two ticks past it and then popped up
to new highs
okay here's a couple that sort of blew
through then you got a selling one here
okay 49 4009 down 205.
all right so you know the whole point of
making these videos for you guys is to
get you thinking on how you can adapt
order flow you don't have to trade it
one way oh Mike says I have to use a
four to one I use a four to one but you
could use a ten to one use a stacked
imbalance of two imbalances right it
doesn't have to be three if you're using
a higher percentage
okay I mean you know this was on Friday
right if you go back I mean on the night
session you know here's a stacked one at
7 30 in the evening right you see the
market came off came back up within a
tick of it and sold off
um was there any more during the
the European hours let me see
I'm not sure you know okay we got it
here
came down just traded two ticks through
before it rallied up there was a selling
of balance from earlier
um you know that one failed okay fine
you know here's one came right back to
it at four in the morning
or 404 and it popped back up okay so you
know hopefully I'm getting those you can
get in your brain starting to think
outside of the box outside of sort of
the standard way of using order flow so
that you could adapt it and make it your
own really that that's what trading is
about is about getting an idea and
making it your own rather than copying
exactly turning into well this is what
so-and-so does I have to do this no you
know you could make that adjustment to
improve your trading so I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll catch you
guys on the next video bye-bye